research studying psychology found out
that both second person and third person
makes you more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say i want to do this i
want to do this you want to do what we
call in the book self-coaching
where you would say you know in my case
yeah
brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it
is yes yes another one another one i do
every morning yeah assuming i take a
shower but every morning the shower
because we all don't every day not every
morning no we do not this doesn't happen
it does not happen i told you like 24
hours ago i was staying in a barn in the
woods at a friend's house um
but the second thing i ask myself in the
in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate you know something's gonna go
wrong during the day absolutely and if i
already know everything like like this
morning's was okay
you're in
i think what we would i think i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying what
do you call it north you're uptown i'm
uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown okay so i'm like
okay that's gonna be 45 minutes it's a
hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get impatient yes and i
get stressed and i don't want to feel
that so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with marie brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here i know that sounds
completely crazy but every high
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it i mean at high level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers
they all
self-talk and most of them we found
we're doing it in second and third
person which is amazing i love it yeah i
think it's so fun yeah little things
yeah so if you already talk to yourself
and you say your name to yourself
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing most of us never take control
of our self-talk you don't
take control of the thoughts that you
have about yourself when you're by
yourself it doesn't even matter as much
what our parents think what our friends
think what our husband or wife thinks
it's you you're the problem you think
negatively about yourself you
are not consistently filling yourself
with thoughts with positivity with
ambition with courage the default
pattern is one of mediocrity of one of i
can't do this one of lack of
resourcefulness and so that's what you
live
and it's possible to change
and in making that shift and making that
change you become an entirely different
person we talk about
how to become the best version of
yourself how do you live your life how
do you how do you show up as that proud
version this is it
it's taking control of the automatic
self-talk that you have to yourself even
if you don't actually talk to yourself
even if you're not saying
evan you're an idiot right evan you
can't do that even if you're not saying
those things out loud you're feeling
those things
it's at a subconscious level
and this is where you're playing small
and they've been limiting yourself so
let me share example from from my
background and then also give you some
tactical specific tangible things you
can do to start to break free to start
to actually live the life that you say
that you want to live
i
am afraid a lot
i'm afraid a lot and i used to let that
fear dominate me i used to let that fear
prevent me from doing the thing that i
needed to do whether it's making videos
whether it's speaking on stage whether
it's interviewing people
i don't believe in being fearless i
think if you're fearless it means that
you are just doing the things that are
inside your comfort zone you're
photocopying your life i think if you're
fearless you actually hate your life
because you're just doing things that
you know how to do i think fear is a
great thing
it's not being fearless it's having the
fear and then showing up because of not
even the spite of because of because
you're afraid then you have to go do the
thing
because you're worried then you have to
go do the thing because you're
afraid of somebody's judgment and you
have to go to just because just to teach
yourself that you do it so
for me speaking on stage
doing interviews
making videos were the three that i
struggled with the most this guy who's
made 10 000 videos has spoken in front
of thousands of people have done
interviews with some of the biggest
people on the planet i'm still afraid
every time
i'm still afraid every time
and i don't let that fear now stop me
from doing the thing
i'm still you know i had tony robbins on
my channel
and i had them on three years or two
years before
but i'm still nervous to have them on my
heart's still beating my crazy i'm still
an emotional wreck the day of i'm still
not focused
on anything else i can't do any other
work i can't make any other videos
because i'm i'm stressed about the
interview going well i still worry about
these things it doesn't go away there's
just levels to this
and i still want to show up
where old evan younger evan used to find
a reason why i couldn't do it
find a reason why i couldn't show up
live in the fear and justify it as an
actual reason or excuse but deep down i
was just afraid think about your reasons
like why can't you do this thing what
are you telling yourself that you can't
do really deep down it's just a fear
you're just afraid
there's no really good reason you've
convinced yourself there's a reason but
deep down you're just afraid
right if you're actually honest with
yourself you're just afraid
so how do you get out of it how do you
start to shift the narrative how do you
start to identify the self-talk that's
been automatic and in your brain
consistently for years or maybe decades
how do you start to make that shift
happen
number one
is to
spend a little time with yourself
and and finish the sentence i am what i
am blank i am blank what's the blank you
are what if you're just by yourself you
have a little space to breathe from your
environment you are what what are some
of the words that come up what are some
of the positive words what are some of
the negative words that show up if
you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hopefully some positive ones
so
um for me it could be i'm someone who
believes i am
uh
i am a great husband
so i'm paying attention i am you know a
great father i am a
great
not owner what do you do with dogs i
don't know like great you're still
considering your kids they're my kids
yeah dog kids pet kids
all right you know i am i bet then on
the negative side like i am
uh afraid of disappointing people i am
scared of speaking on stages i'm worried
that i'm gonna
ask bad interview questions like what
are the positive and negatives if you
feel in the i am okay just to get
awareness of yourself this starts to
uncover some of the subconscious
behavior that you're living on autopilot
right the subconscious is the autopilot
it's what you're doing by default the
conscious of what we want to
take control of to then turn into
subconscious to then make
the automatic
the positive the ambitious the bold the
courageous right
so start with i am what that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words so
what are the trigger words that you use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing so my three trigger words
are scary difficult or hard that when i
say
scary
difficult hard
those used to be the reasons why i
couldn't do something those used to be
the reasons why i would let myself off
the hook those used to be the things
that would tell myself oh i can't do
this because it's scary i can't do this
because it's difficult i won't show up
because it's hard
and i would let myself off the hook for
those things that i would say oh that's
okay because it's scary so i'm not going
to do it
and and i would that used to be my
identity
and identifying the trigger words
what then allows you to do is move the
step number three where you
use them to take the action that you
want to take instead that when you're
thinking it because those are the
automatic patterns that are in your head
your subconscious great
when i say those things when i feel
those things when i text those things
when i write those things and i have a
conversation those things come out of my
mouth come out of my brain if i'm
thinking about it to myself then i have
to do it just because
scary difficult or hard
and what that does and that's those are
mine and you can adopt them as your own
but i'd rather you go through the i am
process to figure out what they are for
you
what it does is help you
live the life that you're proud of that
when you say oh that's that's just too
hard you're not allowed to say that
anymore
you're not allowed to say that feel that
think that
as soon as you say it then you have to
immediately go do the thing even if it
doesn't work out even if you look like a
fool even if even if x y z happens
you're gonna do it it's worth it because
you're you're reprogramming your
identity
as a bonus step you tell the people
around you
so nina nina stepped out but
uh nina my son my team my family
i'll let them know hey if i say scary
difficult or hard i want you to let me
know
if i say
to you in any conversation i can't
because it's scary or it's difficult or
it's hard i need you to call me out on
it
because i'm not i still don't catch all
of them
it's
a lot more than it used to be and i'm
probably i don't know 90 95 percent of
the way there but there'll still be some
small percentage and having people hold
you accountable
is really important
now the default thinking for them is
gonna be what are you talking about you
you're always doing all of these things
you're always
showing up you're always doing scary
difficult hard in in my case
yeah but not like i could be
there's there's another level to this
and everything i want out of life my
mission my my
vision my boldness is on the other side
my great life is on the other side of
even more scary difficult and hard
i have to start living it
and so i need help in catching it so you
use yourself
as step one as the first part but then
if you can
as a bonus bring in the accountability
to the other people in your life who can
help you catch it and you're not allowed
to get angry at them
you're not allowed to get frustrated
with them
if if you say one of your trigger words
and they say you just said it
you're going to want to say nah but
she's this that doesn't count it doesn't
mean it i was thinking something stop
letting yourself off the hook
and said you say you're right i need to
go do the thing and the more you can
train that
trigger word came up i'm doing the thing
trigger came up and doing the thing
trigger work him up and do the thing
it's scary i'm doing it it's difficult
i'm doing it's hard i'm doing it just
because you start shifting your identity
you start changing your self-talk
now you start to become the person
that you're proud of you start to become
the person that you you say you want to
be you start to actually become the
person you've become the best version of
you
that's how you tangibly change your
self-talk tangibly change the thoughts
that are
running your system that are keeping you
small keeping you scared keeping you way
below your potential
and when everybody else in the world is
letting you off the hook saying what a
great job you're doing you know
that you keep pulling more you know that
when you sit down by yourself when you
look in the mirror
there's not all love there
right you love yourself you see love
when you look back in the mirror when
you do the i am exercise is it only
positive
we have to start getting honest with
ourselves this is the process to change
it and if you did that every day
you're not going to catch it all the
time don't worry about being perfect
this isn't a game about being perfect
it's about making progress
it's about
taking the step every day building
momentum if you did that if you could
just find your trigger words
and then every day
that you catch it do something about it
even if it's some small thing
your entire life will change
the way you show up in your life in your
relationships in your business towards
your customers towards your team all of
it all of it changes all of it changes
suddenly you're not impaired anymore
suddenly you're a lot more creative
where did it come from where did this
extra courage come from
how am i not handicapped anymore by the
things that used to
slow me down
this will be you
and i want you to get there faster
and this is the process to do it so you
can start living the life that you know
you're capable of
change your self-talk
change your life
good luck now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you just get
motivated when you watch a video like
this you just get motivated the sign
says you have a 35 chance of actually
following through that's not good enough
believe nation we are a bunch of action
takers it has to happen so here's how
you do it when you actually create a
plan when you write down what time what
place where you're actually going to
take action your number jumps from 35 to
91 chance of following through and when
you commit to other people like leaving
a comment down below your number jumps
to 95 chance of following through i want
that for you so believe nation your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week i'm going to take one of your
comments and feature it in a future
video so i can celebrate you let me know
in the comments below i remember when i
was going to start my business and i i
really wanted to be good at it you know
i was trying to become an author and a
speaker and do these types of videos and
do some online training for people on
the topics of motivation and marketing
and you know some all these people are
saying well brendan you know you may or
may not be successful that you're you
know blah blah and i thought it's a
weird thing it's not like there's a
trait of successful people you look
across history and successful people
it's not uh they're not from a given
background they don't come from a
specific economic stature they're not in
a position where you know they're
they're one demographic or another
democrat i mean it's all over i mean
we've got thousands of collective years
of history people succeed some people do
some people don't and i think it more
comes down to how do we manage our mind
and how do we manage our days
and i think that there's a difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about
approaching something new you know i
think unsuccessful people when they have
a big dream and they start thinking
about what's going to be required to
accomplish that dream they get very
limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well uh you know i don't
know how to do that
so they stop
they say you know i i don't have those
things
so they stop
or they say i don't know i you know i'm
not like those people i'm not like that
and so they stop
but successful people have a different
way the same thing everybody dreams you
dream i dream successful people dream
people just starting out everybody
dreams everyone has a vision everyone if
they can just take five minutes today
and think about their lives we could all
come up with ways to improve our lives
and reach another level of success joy
happiness achievement contribution
fulfillment soul you know we can all
elevate
but the challenge is that unsuccessful
people they keep stopping when they
think of what they currently know have
or are
but successful people say well i want to
do that but i don't know how to do that
but instead of stopping they say well
then my job
is to go learn that
they take their current limitation
and they put it on their agenda
as a job to do as a thing to figure out
a thing to make happen instead of saying
well i don't have that
they say well then my job is to go build
that or i'm not like that then they say
well then my job is to go become more of
that become that person who could
accomplish those things you know when i
was starting to do online marketing for
the first time and and i don't know if
you how much of my story you know but
when i started doing online marketing i
was literally bankrupt and i went from a
place of bankruptcy to the point where i
really committed to becoming successful
at it and in 18 months i made 4.8
million dollars uh 4.6 collected i mean
it was a huge leap right in indifference
from bankrupt to multi-millionaire in
the span of 18 months
but what made that breakthrough wasn't
that i had new opportunities it wasn't
that i had new technologies it was like
wow there's the internet now those
things were already there
it went i went from this level of
thinking to this level of thinking i
used to say well i i don't know how to
build a web page
so i said agenda figure out how to build
a web page and i spent hours and hours
and hours at nights on weekends from my
job figuring out how to do that and i
said well i don't have one of those
lists you know i don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who i am so i
said job
go build a list go get subscribers go
add value and content out the
marketplace and they'll come i mean just
keep putting stuff out there and i also
didn't say oh my gosh well i have that
dream i can't have that because i'm not
like that because i wasn't a public
speaker i didn't know how to do video i
wasn't like well i'm not one of those
video people well i'm not a public
speaker so i said you know what i have
to go learn that art i have to go become
a better speaker a better communicator i
have to go become more confident i have
to go become a person capable of doing
these things i have to change myself to
get there i can't wait for circumstances
to change so i can have my dream then
our dreams would never happen we have to
get to the point of maturity in our
lives where we say okay two things are
gonna change my life something new is
gonna come into my life and make me
lucky and blessed and maybe i can't
count on that forever and maybe now
instead i have to consciously design my
life and say okay now if i want to
change if i want my dream something new
has to come from me
i'm going to become a better person i'm
going to become a person who is more
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because i am that now
but because we can grow
that you can become the type of person
who needs to uh who you need to be to
achieve your ideal life you can start
today living from your highest ideals
your highest sense of self your
strongest sense of self you don't need
permission you don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera and say you
have now permission but if you've been
waiting for it you have permission
it's like at some point in your life you
just say okay i have permission to
become my best self and by becoming your
best self you start to achieve your best
things you start to contribute better
things you start to become a better
human being you can do that now today so
next time you're thinking about a big
dream don't think about the things that
well i don't know how to do that and
stop think i don't know how so set it up
on your calendar to go learn those
things i don't have that then set it up
step by step to go build that i'm not
like that then set it up step by step to
go develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop now i know you all have big goals
big dreams big aspirations just like i
do you've got ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you'll fall off and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge i
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you can't keep the habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
more on a more regular basis and then it
goes away or you say you know i'm going
to be more kind and more patient and
more awesome to my partner my lover and
you start being nice for two or three
days and then on the fourth day you're a
jerk you know and you're like
what happened i said i was gonna be
nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret i've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so
simple but most people don't have it
it's called trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits
what do i mean by that
well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your your journal or set
up on a vision board that you look at
once in a while but in day-to-day life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense
well let's use that idea let's use that
idea by setting up alarms on our phones
that trigger us to do the very things we
need to do this is gonna be so basic
you're gonna laugh and then also tell
you how i've literally taught this to
fortune 50 ceos and they said it was the
one thing that changed their life the
most dramatically so let's start with
this let's have a goal in mind let's say
you want to become
more
present
and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal i'm going to be more present and
calm you could meditate in the morning
saying today i'm gonna be more present
and calm and you could you could start
out with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take ten deep breaths in
remind yourself to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths
and then again it happens at 2 o'clock
and again it happens at 6 00 pm and
again it happens at 8pm
what's going to happen you always look
at your phone don't you it's gonna go
throughout the day you're gonna forget
and the funniest thing is i've had so
many people do this worldwide we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people i've taught to do this hundreds
of thousands and they tell me all the
time that changed everything and you'll
think once you set it up that the next
day
you you'll you'll forget about it no
that alarm will go off you forgot you
set the dang alarm there it goes off in
your face you're like all right i'm
trying to be calmer
and more present close my eyes take 10
deep breaths reground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
behavior i know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
because they never set those things up
so what if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
spectrum i don't want to just be calmer
and more present i want more energy
throughout the day so here's what i do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair i don't care
if i'm on a plane or i was like where
we're shooting here i wrote a lot of my
books here i wrote the motivation
manifesto here i wrote the charge here
and if i'm going to write
my butt hits the chair i grab my phone i
open the timer and i set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes
it starts buzzing and i look at that and
i go oh that's my trigger to get energy
so i stand up i go get some water i take
a glass of water drink it down i do some
stretches and i do some exercise just
really briefly or i'll go for a walk
whatever it is but i'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes
then i'll sit back down i'll set that 50
min alarm and i'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me
to change how i'm physically moving it
changes my attention so that throughout
the day i'm continually refreshed so i
never have that two three four o'clock
time where i'm like ah
you know why because i've triggered my
day so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action
drop kids off is go to health food store
or let's say you want to get healthier
in the morning one of the easiest ways
to help people maintain a better
exercise program is this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise
shoes on uh might get dressed if you're
naked just saying so you get dressed put
your shoes on you go downstairs or you
go to the gym and that's the trigger you
woke up you do these actions nothing
interrupts those actions that's the
action
and you have to have those set up
one of my other favorite
trigger moments to set up is door frame
triggers what do you mean by that when
you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if i walk into my house
at night after like if i've been working
all day and i'm gonna walk in i'm gonna
see my lady
i have it so when i ever walk through
the doors of my house three words repeat
off immediately in my mind because i've
done it so many times consciously i went
to the door i said the three words said
three words said the three words and i
did this so many times that now when i
walk through a door my mind
automatically triggers those three words
and i remember to be those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you
what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life i teach executives do this as well
i have them have a door frame trigger
when they walk into their office in the
morning as soon as they walk through
that door frame they have boom three
words go through their mind about how
they want to be perceived as a leader i
have them set up another dwarf every
time they walk into a meeting into the
conference room when they walk through
the doors of the conference room they
have another three words that trigger
off for them and it just reminds them
how to be
so these aren't big crazy things a lot
of people they think they have to
completely change your life what would
change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and i promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
you have to be all in and it's the
hardest thing to do because if it fails
then you can feel like a failure um you
know
i think of this idea of performance
necessity um two stories kind of come to
mind one is i was working with an
olympic gold medalist sprinter and we're
in the tunnel and we're going out and
he's talking about the competition and
we get out to the blocks and i said uh
he was really worried about the
competition i said well how do you
engage like who who who's gonna win
you know in in his particular race
people are winning but by you know 1
100th of a second tenths of a seconds i
mean these are really close sprints and
i said well how how do you know
i said who would you even bet on
and he says
you know i would
bet on the guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line and says
i got to do this
for my mom
and i was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is
it's necessary for him to win that race
for his mom
um i think of
you know when i started
my career and i really decided to go all
in
with writing and online training
this is like 2000 probably six
i'd gone broke completely bankrupt and
failed i left my corporate job i had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job um left it to write
and i didn't know how to make it as a
writer i want to do seminars workshops
didn't know how to do that so i was
pretty much a hot mess ran out of money
um i got nothing to my name nothing kind
of no positive prospects no one's
calling me except the guys who want the
money
and um
one night i'm riding and the apartment
was so small on the bed i had uh
my bills my vision boards all my
research
all my journals like the bed was
basically the desk the extended desk and
my lady comes in denise and
she
walks past me but she sees i'm like
trying to write
so it doesn't disturb me she goes she
crawls under
the covers of the bed
and i'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and i look over
and
i see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know
because none of us want to see our you
know
our family suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
i was just like
i gotta figure this out
and i'm telling you i wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day i wrote more than ever that
burst life scold and ticket which became
a bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because i was like i'm going to
figure out this online thing i'm going
throughout marketing i'm going to figure
out how to teach i'm going to how to
train and get paid for it because i've
never really been paid for those things
i said i'm going to figure out this
industry and i'm going to make it 18
months later after her
crawling under the bills i made 4.6
million dollars jesus online
total transformation people like how did
you do it i'm like she gave me she was
my necessity i was not going to let my
woman
be in that situation
um
and she believed in me she supported me
she she married me
and uh you know but that was she was my
drive
and the second part was i went all in
with my identity i said i am going to be
a great writer
and i am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over two million people
have taken our online courses video
series now
i don't think it would have happened if
i hadn't had the guts and maybe the no
other choice
to say this is who i'm going to be
and i'm going to build into that
and it's necessary for me to become that
person
so let's go you know the first way you
should not compare yourself to others is
in terms of especially today their fans
their fame their followership right
their audience never do that
in my industry that's very very popular
to do and it's ruined a lot of people's
lives who don't ever rise up to serve
because they think they're not popular
enough you know it's like that you write
your first book and you don't have as
many sales as other people and you think
oh well i don't have the audience or you
go to someone's fan page and you see oh
my gosh look at their followership look
at how many instagram followers they
have how many twitter followers they
have and and because you see them so big
you think oh i could never be that so
you don't even begin and a lot of people
do that they say well i'm not that big
so they never start
but as i always say you know what no
matter how small you start start
something that matters begin it if i
began my career looking at my heroes
looking at a wayne dyer or a tony
robbins or marianne williamson a deepak
chopra a jim rohn back in the day or or
looking at people like augmentinos who'd
sold millions of books or or even the
famous books that you saw millions and
millions and millions of copies if i
gauged myself to that and thought that
was the expectation
i would never begin
so you can't expect to start out with
tons of people some some people say to
me all the time well brennan it's so
easy for you because you got millions of
people on your email list and you have
millions of people on facebook and tens
of millions on youtube i say it doesn't
make it any harder for me i still show
up and shoot this video and the reason i
have the followers and the fans and the
audience is because i showed up and i
started when there was only one dude 10
dudes 100 dudes a thousand dudes
watching us my first seminar that i ever
did we we only had 22 people
in the room and now we fill up seminars
nine times a year often from people from
46 countries around the world fly in
paying thousands of dollars a ticket and
what did i do i i started with 22 people
in a room and most of those people
didn't even pay and every time the the
guy walked in with with water i counted
him as one of those 22.
like i i had no followership it's never
about how big you start it's that you
start and you get big by staying at it
because what people do is they put out
the first video they write their first
book they they try their first thing
online and nobody follows nobody watches
and they quit they get disappointed
and where there's disappointment there
was too high of as an expectation on
achievement versus learning versus
process versus beginning
what you want to do is never be
disappointed and the way that you're
never disappointed is you understand
every single step counts every single
step is learning every single step gets
you going but if you have the aspiration
or the the attention that's only focused
on their followership and meeting that
you'll never begin don't compare your
followership to anybody else's instead
just compare your work ethic be there
show up work get it done the second
thing i want you to compare yourself to
is other people's achievements that
means their wealth their sales number
their uh big house their big car their
whatever else you know their fancy
clothes their whatever they got don't
look at other people's achievements and
what they have
because if you do that it's also you
think well i'm not famous enough and
then you think well i'm not lucky enough
blessed enough rich enough whatever your
excuse becomes you gotta be get very
very very careful of that and i know you
know that but
lately have you been looking at other
people's stuff
and feeling demoralized because of that
well i you know they had a silver spoon
in their mouth or they're so lucky
those types of things stop us from even
trying because we feel like the game is
unfair well it's not most wealthy people
especially all the billionaires i've met
and i've been blessed to meet lots of
them and coach a few of them the mega
stars i get to work with the olympians i
get to work with the highest achieving
people in the world they it's not luck
and most of them didn't have
unbelievable lucky family connections
what they did is they hustled they
worked they built it and even if they
started a little more abundant than
other people
they outlasted their peers who also
started out abundant because they gave
they worked they struggled through and
we got to keep going
the third thing don't compare yourself
ever in terms of looks appearances
beauty you know i i know if you're
somebody who opens up those fashion
magazines or those celebrity gossip
magazines you're always looking oh she's
cuter than me oh he's better looking and
then again you have the excuse as soon
as you compare yourself to other people
you have the excuse to never begin you
have the reason to be demoralized i mean
there's if i looked across youtube when
i started doing my episodes or my videos
or or itunes or podcasts you know i
would have never begun because you've
got all these people out there they're
like they're amazing they look so good
they sound so good and i sucked i
couldn't talk like this before now as
you know all of our videos and every
episode i've ever done has been
unscripted no notes i got nothing i'm
looking right at you there's nothing in
front of me i just go and they're all in
one single take majority of them i think
99 are one
take
and that came from practice where for
years and years and years years and
years and years i i tried to be able to
just speak extemporaneously without
using notes without using a script i
taught myself to do this
and if i'd compared myself to other
people who were so polished and looking
good and every word was precise i would
have never gotten to where we're at
today with literally hundreds of
millions of views and from our posts to
our videos it came because i didn't
worry about the polish of looking like
everybody else i was just doing my thing
so what should you compare why should
you be comparing yourself to others
for growth reasons learning reasons i
mean the first reason you should always
compare yourself to others is for
creativity to get ideas not to steal and
not to compare but rather to go oh how
would i do that it you know in comparing
yourself to others it brings in
self-awareness to say oh look this is
how i'm distinct this is how i'm
different this is how i could approach
this in a different way
if i didn't research the market i would
never know how i could be different if i
didn't know how it could be different i
could never have a business
you cannot build a business or have a
real career or make any major
contribution without understanding how
you're distinct steve jobs knew that
when he built the phone it was different
and that
thinking differently is what made him an
icon it's the same for everything that
we do compare so you know what is out
there so you know how you can bring a
new creative edge to it second reason to
compare is to compare for vision
because as you get self-awareness and
you understand how you're distinct
sometimes you see someone doing
something amazing and you're like wow
i got a bigger vision for myself when i
started seeing people posting videos you
know back in
2007 i got a bigger vision for myself i
mean 2007 i saw people posting longer
videos online i thought
wow i never saw myself doing video but
look at how i'm watching these and i'm
relating with these i got to do some
video and by comparing myself to others
some other people i followed or
researched or read their books and i saw
they had a podcast i'm like i'm going to
get a
podcast it opened up my vision
for the vehicles the mediums the the
ways that i could serve and give and i
want you to do the same and the last
piece the reason to compare yourself is
for growth
there is an amazing amount of talent in
this world and when you see them it
should inspire you to level up it it
inspired me to learn how to do video it
inspired me to learn how to speak
extemporaneous and it inspired me to get
over my fears of public speaking step on
a stage and now it's in front of
thousands and thousands of people to
inspire the world i never i never
thought i could do that but seeing other
people sometimes achieve the remarkable
you get inspired if it's not about if
you can look at someone who's done
something better than you and it
inspires you that means
you have humility
and you got a chance
if you look at other people who've
achieved more have more look more feel
good or are more amazing than you and
you get bitter or upset that means
you're small and you're destined to
smallness
but if you can look at greatness and be
inspired you're on track you're going to
live an extraordinary quality of life
the kind of life that we call the charge
delay in our lives
especially when we're being
reactive
information comes in
right we're at advance we're paying
attention to how people treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something
and we're just going about a regular day
information is coming in how people
perceive us
the cause and effect of events
things are just happening
information comes into the brain from
that point the information immediately
goes into
interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is safe
unsafe
good
bad
like it
don't like it
recognize it
don't recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar familiar
certain uncertain fear safe all these
things start triggering it's pretty
unconscious and it's pretty fast our
biases come into play it's just that
speed spontaneous reactive part of us
and it's that's not always bad sometimes
it can be good
right sometimes it can be good
interpretation can be that event that's
good for me or that events that's bad
for me but usually it's like a snap
judgment think about that most
most when we're talking about an
unconscious level it's like a snap
judgment automatic like you like her
don't like her
feel safe don't feel safe it's very fast
then the next level
and this is not always linear of course
because your brain
is not left brain
right brain
kind of
methodology your brain's more of a
spider web of interconnectedness
that is something we still don't
understand okay you can study everything
in neuroscience and you might learn
something about this lobe or that
that cortex region but then only to find
out that later on a year later like well
actually it seems like it's also
communicating over here it's a spider
web of unbelievable
intelligence it's happening that and
everything can be millisecond
hundreds of million seconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast unbelievable
capable so this is just for our
understanding it's not necessarily real
world linear like this but what tends to
happen is as information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean
to
me
identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this say
about me
how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this can
be really troublesome some of you
discovered that yesterday i bet when you
released a few things sometimes we have
these events in our life that we we take
on and we just assume it meant something
about us and we didn't realize no that's
more of a statement about them than is
about us
right sometimes when you're hurt or
someone was rude to you it had nothing
to do with you raise your hand you
follow
i had nothing to do with you but if
you're not careful
you could say
mean person
unsafe means i'm bad child
rude behavior
uncertain about this
i must not be long
terrible situation
i feel bad
i can never be safe again
how many follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because how these things get
labeled can really change our lives
forever
well imagine like last night i'm going
on the stage right if i if my identity
says i am a public speaker and it's
important for me to be excellent at this
and then i go on stage and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity because that risk of
disappointment or rejection you know if
the task fails
you shouldn't take that as as a defining
moment in which you say i am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped on its face and go
well actually
um
no i do get bothered
if it fails i really get upset about it
i am attached to
the process here i i do care if it turns
out well i mean that's why they obsess
about the details that's why they care
about excellence is like no one obsessed
about the details or cares about
excellence unless it means something to
them
and there is a risk the risk is
you over attach
to
the process of the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human
and now you stop your progress
but i also tell people
there's a balance there
i actually wish more people would attach
some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much i mean i
think what the world needs
less of is half interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what
i'm going to be an excellent parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they i want them to own the
identity of a ceo because most of them
if you ask about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists it's like if you want
to win
your identity has to be tied into that
thing in which you are trying to succeed
at and give to and that takes a lot of
guts to put yourself all in for
something but who's ever contributed
something with tremendous impact without
being all into it i've never seen it so
i think the message of the book you're
right i'll get some flack of people a
lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity or my friends who are buddhists
say but attachment is the form of all
suffering brandon have you not read your
spiritual attacks i'm like look out calm
down i've hung out with the dalai lama
i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you
is even the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader his identity is still
there that people
you know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having any
attachment to something but i'm like i
think
we all want to be present
and engaged fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i
am all in this
it's what i'm about it's the habit is
generate energy
okay not necessarily have energy create
energy create energy and what they do
the way we measure that was kind of
academic
mental energy which is tied to your
focus and your stamina and your ability
to manage complex tasks without too much
mental stress
number two is emotional energy
which is just the quality of positive
emotions
and number three is physical energy
high performers are forty percent more
likely to work out five times per week
than
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15 percent most high performing
people in the world
tend to work out five days per week
and that workout could be defined as you
know 45-minute brisk walk or you know
hit intensity or whatever it is but
40
more likely that's a huge finding
and what we found is high performers
just have
better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
one stunning finding was uh
ceos
senior executives and business owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now i
can imagine yeah yeah i kind of i was
surprised by that i would thought you
know athletes would be ten percent more
i mean the emotional and mental energy
yeah
the decision making the conversations
the big deals the stakeness yeah it's a
lot of energy it's a lot that's why
i mean if you really want to achieve
your dreams you have to care for your
body yeah your mind it's why all these
things you know finally resonating in
the marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break
or you know uh
managing your own energy sleep is
everything yeah um and i think all of
that is really important and we say
generate energy because there's this
myth that
you know some people have happiness or
they have it's like
no you generate you don't have happiness
you generally create it yeah you create
it and so
the quality of your energy you have to
create like you and i both i mean if
most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days is like how is lewis even able
to focus right now and how are you able
to get here and do this as well yeah but
it's because we say well this is our
mission
show up man you know there's plenty of
times i gotta imagine you walked on the
field and you were like
i'm spam exhausted you know i remember
when you like flew down to compete
yeah i still play with the usa team
handball yeah team and a year ago i flew
down to
i remember i did an interview in miami
and then flew out from miami and then
went and just went right into training
camp and then played against brazil
which is like you know olympic
olympic qualifiers and yeah got our
assets booked but it was fun you know
but i had to have clarity yeah she
didn't show up even when i was like oh
we're gonna lose yeah like there's zero
chance yeah it was like the worst team
in the nba playing like the warriors and
we were just like we had no chance yeah
but i had to show up and give my best
and you have to set all these routine i
mean you know the amount of routines tom
brady has in his life so that he can
generate energy it's unbelievable stuns
most people it's unbelievable and that's
just that's that's what it takes if you
want to get that level if you don't want
to be at that level you don't have to do
it yeah you don't have to do it i mean
everybody can just like well i'm going
to go you know hit the cinnabon but it's
pretty good how do you want to feel at
three o'clock if you want to feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a cinnabon one of the major major
keys we found the first high-performing
habit is seek clarity
and what we found is
one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same like we have they're physical
they're almost always automatic even
though when the brain is creating
associations there's also happen for us
it's kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
i'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues right you're just like you know
uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of
what that emotion was and how it sticks
and the meaning we give it to it yeah
and the example i used you know i like
to give and i don't remember if it's in
the book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was 1481 when i finished baby you
edited it down yes and it was 1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but i was like that's going to freak
people out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and just
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but um the example i
like to give is if you and i go to a
haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if you and i walk around you
know you walk around on the walls in a
haunted house someone jumps out at you
yeah you and i are both going to jump
yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright immediately it's going
to be there right but i might be freaked
out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is look if at six like
we we go to the haunted house at you
know 5 p.m in the afternoon
if at 9 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel
scared
that's not the haunted house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still experiencing that
feeling
that's a mental job
not an emotional job
so your job is to go wow
i'm at my house i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i got to redefine the feeling i wanna
experience and i work with one an
olympic sprinter gold medalist olympic
sprinter as a client and
this person's huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold i said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was i
learned to define the feeling
and i said what do you mean by that and
he basically said
you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way i want
to feel in this race right now i know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating i can hear everybody i'm waiting
for that shot blast i i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these um like their emotions are there
yeah but that person is defining the
feeling i'm going to feel centered now
i'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all olympic
level com competitors all of them but
they define that feat that emotion as a
feeling that helps give them a
performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like
nerves he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently it's so simple
like when you get the life is really
short and you felt that before but
either by you were threatened or you've
had some near near and dear die but when
you have that real essence in you that
says life is short have reverence for it
live it that's a really big thing i got
that at 19 and i learned specifically
that
if we have a moment of cognition before
the end of our life
we tend to
ask questions to evaluate if we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's going to come from that experience
where
i learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine
what the questions you're going to ask
at the end of your life are going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end
for me the answers the questions i had
were did i live
which i hadn't i hadn't been living my
life i've been thinking about taking my
life
did i love
no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people and i always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up to keep
out the bad guys prevent the good guys
from getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is connection
and i learned that i would ask did i
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark caribbean night i'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
bleeding out
my friend
and i just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car
looking down all this blood
and i'm in terror
and i just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did i even
matter you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid i didn't know
about impact theory
for real i didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that i didn't know to think about
legacy
meaning
did i matter i didn't think i did
but the good news is i'm a good learner
and i felt like i got a second chance
from god that night and i learned
that it was really important for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again i'll know
i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to know know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally dude if you're angry all
the time you got to change how you look
at the world
yes there's a lot in the news that can
piss you off yes there's a lot going on
that causes outrage all day long on
twitter or social media somewhere but if
that's your sole focus no wonder you're
upset all the time lots of people are
angry right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new
there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know are as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world
i mean the odds that you're even alive
and having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up you know one of my late
mentors was wayne dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground he said
thank you
thank you
thank you
he was grateful for his day and he began
that way and i think so many people
right now they kind of roll up in bed
and they're like
and they grab their freaking phone and
they start going through the news and
social media and what are they cueing
immediately i'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
click make look at me click clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your a game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be
solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem problem
problem outrage outrage but listen when
you become a solution-based person when
you say okay i actually want to do
something about this problem and you
start taking positive steps to at least
address it or to participate suddenly
that anger goes into a new fire and that
fire is called enthusiasm
it is easy to switch anger into
enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay i
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation
turns anger often into enthusiasm and so
if you're just stewing on the things you
don't like of course it's going to be a
negative energy but if you start stewing
on the things that you can do
you find personal power you find
enthusiasm you find social contribution
ultimately you find community because
one reason it's so easy to be angry is
when you're alone
you're at home you're sort of thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about all the negative things and you
don't have an outlet of other human
beings to discuss with
especially solution oriented people or
people with ideas and dreams and
ambitions people who are doing stuff
with their life because listen
when you're on a path of purpose you
ain't got time for drama
i don't have time for a ton of anger in
my life because i'm too busy making
positive changes that's where we want to
get you we want to shift your attention
and focus in the morning we want to
start making you more solution based and
get your community of people around who
are ambitious and driven to change and
to make positive change happen when we
do that the anger starts going away and
if you can't get over the anger yourself
then don't be shy about asking for help
you know a lot of people they don't have
anybody to talk to so i'm like get a
therapist man get in a group man talk
with some people go to a seminar get in
a new sort of environment you want to
get rid of the anger go volunteer get
around other people who are making
positive impacts that community that
shift
changes your life you don't have to be
angry anymore and the last part about
that
is letting go
you got to let go of those things that
upset you three years ago five years ago
10 years ago if you're an adult and
you're still angry and pissed about
things that happened to you in high
school
you need a therapist
and i say that with all
sincerity and all respect
if you're having mental thoughts that
are coming from a place that are
literally based five 10 20 years ago
that you just didn't deal with yet you
need help dealing with it and you need
to get yourself a meditation practice or
a therapist or in some kind of way that
you're on a consistent basis letting
things go here's what i do every sunday
i go okay what was i pissed about this
last week what really bothered me okay
i gotta let that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you gotta
let it go you gotta find a clean slate
for yourself so that your your soul can
expand and can be positive and can be
ambitious and motivated and serving the
next week because listen anger after
anger after anger hatred after hatred
after hatred criticism after criticism
after criticism rejection after
rejection after rejection outrage after
outrage after outrage it weighs you down
so you've got to change how much of that
you're taking in and you've got to make
sure every single week you're doing some
kind of like mental detox to let that
stuff go and instead of cultivating the
anger cultivate the gratitude cultivate
the enthusiasm and you can change your
life if you want another amazing brendan
burchard video check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there